don't you think and i want you to be
honest about this you're very honest
person i can tell
you got robbed uh at the emmys
uh i mean patricia got um an emmy for
the act
yeah you were nominated for golden globe
and for an emmy
right and yeah and a sag award and a sag
award on the on the uh
critics choice awards sorry critics
choice too anything we're missing
[Laughter]
good and pissed when uh they announced
michelle williams
i was more um invested in
if i would get a nomination or not so
when i when i got that nomination i
don't know if you saw my video when i
like found out
i was just a puddle of tears i was so
so excited the minute that happened i
was like i don't care what happens i
just cannot believe i'm here
in this category with these people
because to be in the same category as
michelle williams
and amy adams and niecy nash and anjanu
ellis it was just like
arya jokin for the lead in the limited
series
that's and i'm not even trying to be
like correct when i say this like that's
a win
you know that's a huge win in and of
itself
um so being at the emmys
and and sitting there when they're about
to announce the winner and julia
louis-dreyfus is on stage with the whole
cast of veep
announcing who the winner of this
category is my heart was beating out of
my chest
i was like i will pass out
this moment were you nervous because
you'd have to go up as joey king and
accept
is that why you were nervous howard i
think my heart
my heart was beating right when i was in
the zoom green room for this
i just get really like i have a lot of
adrenaline i get really amped about
stuff like i get really excited about
things so my heart was beating so fast
when they were calling out um when they
were about to announce who the winner
was and it's interesting because when
they called michelle williams
i i fully expected to to lose to her i
knew i knew i was going to lose to
somebody but i knew it was probably
going to be michelle
and so i was like oh amazing at the time
i was a 20 year old actress i was
nominated when i was 19. and i
i was like you know that i have not been
around the block as much as these ladies
who are nominated have
i completely didn't expect to win in my
first nomination